um
okay hi everyone um my name is nahin
i'm with you from toronto canada i hope
you had a fun time so far in the
conference and enjoyed
the talks um today i want to talk about
how to develop to be compliant with our
2.1
out of the gate uh ola 2.1 is an in
progress effort to consolidate and
simplify the most commonly used features
of ola 2.0
oof community has patched and added to
the oauth spec over the years
and if you want to implement a secure
oauth
solution today it requires reading so
many rfcs
and best current practices or bcbs
and everyone is now expecting a lot 2.1
to be out and simplify everything today
i want to discuss the details of oauth
2.1 and
development approach for the current
project to be compliant
with uh olat 2.1
in the next 16 minutes i want to go over
the specs uh for to talk about law 2.0
and then the future
which is open or 2.1 and then
a quick demo using identity server 4
which is an open source
library 402 and
open id connect and then following we're
gonna have
um i mean i hope that i can leave some
time for questions
and but but please feel free to reach
out on a slack
to chat or for questioning
okay let's go back for a second and talk
about
problems before jumping to the solution
authentication auto and authorization
are two of main problems on modern web
application security
authentication is needed when an
application needs
to know the identity of the current user
typically these applications manage data
on behalf of the users
and authentication screen
i think you're expecting us to see your
screen right
yep we cannot see anything sorry
oh okay
i'm so sorry
nope one sucks
okay can you see my screen now
yes okay cool cool sorry sorry about
that
okay um
yeah actually this is the first slide
that i wanted you to see
in my screen um so okay um
as i was saying so authentication and
authorization are two of the main
problems
and so when it comes to authentication
we want to know
the application want to know who the
user is is that
is to verify that the user is who they
say they
are and like the solution provided for
authentication is open id connector or
idc and also like these applications
that i'm talking about
uh like which are managing data on
behalf of the user needs to make sure
user can only access the data for which
they are allowed to
right here comes authorization to deal
with granting or denying rights to
access
resources here is a big picture of how
modern application modern web
applications may look like
and and each and every one of these
components or these applications which
are on the screen
are to protect resources and that's why
they need to implement
authentication and authorization so i
have this big picture i'm putting the
solutions in place in them and
if you see like in this picture like for
example browsers communicate with the
web applications
and like if browser-based communicate
with web apis and
apis connect and like communicate with
each other
or work or with web applications but
like
um they can connect on behalf of the
user or just as themselves
and if you see in this solution like in
this
big picture including the solution i
included the authorization server as
well which is
needed for olaf and open id connect so
this is just a big picture
uh let's let's go to more details
right so let's see what is over 2
so oh 2 is the indus industry standard
protocol for
authorization and it is in fact an open
standard
it means open the standard means that
there is no implementation for it there
is some
standard that it is suggested to how to
implement
so oauth is a delegation protocol
which means someone who controls
resource and allow a software
application to access that resource
on their behalf without impersonating
them
means the user is leading an application
and
to access the resources on their behalf
and this application requests
authorization from the owner of this
resource which
is the user and receive a token and to
be able to access those
those resources olaf is a token based
protocol and all what is working over
https
and um as i said it used token
rather than credentials oh it is being
developed by
a ietf oauth working group which
is ietf stand for
internet engineering task force so
to draw actually a better picture of
olaf
and it's necessary to know that its
terminology first right and
um so in like i have um
the list of items in oauth terminology
on the screen
on the left what you see are the main
and then on the right is
just um like details of each one
first one comes the rules in olaf so we
have different roles in oauth
and like including resource owner which
is the entity that can grant access to
the protected resources
and typically it is the end user
the client which is the application it's
the one which is requesting for those
protected resources on behalf of the
resource
owner and um then the user agent
user agent is what user is
using to interact with the client for
example
a browser or a native application like a
native
mobile app and the resource server
resource server
are those protected resources that we
are talking about like apis
and the authorization server which is
actually the main component as
it's the server that authenticates that
user
and issue the access token and to be
able to
access actually to their protected
resources
so the net like we talked about the
client which is that
application who needs to access right
this client has some credentials
uh which is registered to the
authorization server authorization
server
knows what is the what is this client
these credentials contains of client id
and client secret the id is uh as a name
show it's a public
identifier and secret is something that
just the client
and the authorization server are aware
of so
like clients have two types a
confidential and also public
confidentials are those
who can keep that secret safe right they
can do they can authenticate to
authorization server
securely because they have a safe secret
and the public ones are the ones like
mobile apps they cannot keep their
secrets safe
they may run in a browser there by
public ones
uh so and then scopes and the consent
scope is used to express uh what the
application can do on behalf
of the user right and it is always a
subset of what user can do
um it is used for handling of that
delegation that we said olaf
is uh doing and the consent is like
when the application requests for some
scope
this information is shown to the user in
the consent form and user actually can
grant or deny
so then the application will receive a
token with just the
granted the scopes
and the access token access token is the
things that this application uses to
access those protected resources to call
the api
right and for access token is necessary
to
say that there is no defined structure
in this spec for that
but the most common use is barotokens
which are
mostly jwt or job
the grand types grand types for oauth is
the different um use cases it's just um
the use cases are which are implemented
in oauth are
uh provided as a grantor so um
some of them are in the in the um bcps
or
best current practices some are suggests
that
to not be used and um
like but but ola 2.1 is actually making
uh like more concrete suggestions about
this
so here comes client credentials and
authorization code and proof keep for
code exchange or pixie
and the password then implicit so
between this the client credential
and pixie are the ones which are now
suggested to be used on oauth as well
but some rest of them
are still compliant with oauth2
and the endpoints which is um
um like the authorization endpoint and
token endpoint
and first is to just interact with the
resource owner and
then get the grant and the token is
actually to receive the access token
and the last is refresh token which is
allowing the application to obtain a new
access token
without prompting the user so here was
the terminology so it is necessary to
know
to understand what the flow is and then
later we're going to talk about now what
is the
next step which is oh what 2.1 but
without this is
like we need this knowledge to go to
future
so here is the abstract protocol flow
right um and all the components
i i show like we talked about in
terminology you can see them here this
is abstract obviously there is no grant
or use case here
so as you see we have the resource owner
and
we have the client authorization server
and resource server and it's just
showing in
abstract abstract way that how they
interact with each other as
we talk and
now what is over 2.1 now that we know
like the concept of or2 and the
terminology and now
we are ready to go like what is ola 2.1
it is an in progress effort um
now which means that it's not out and if
it's
approved so it's gonna obsolete some
certain part
of the over 2.0 including some of those
brands and mandate
additional security best practices it
is and the rest is gonna stay the same
so
it is here it's gonna be here just to
simplify and provide
a better more concrete way for
developers to simplify
their life and here is the big picture
that i showed you once
of 2.1 is out like
it's going to be like this means that
wherever that we have a over 2.0
gonna be replaced with or 2.1
so nothing is expected to change as far
as we know about this
okay now what are these changes that are
suggested
in the oh a 2.1 the first one comes
with pixi so it's a pixie is required
for
all of clients using the authorization
code flow
so like in in uh us there was some
bcps and some rfcs which was saying that
just use pc for
um like config like a public client
but in or 2.1 it is actually required
for
all like all the clients using
authorization code flow
so let's see first what is authorization
code flow and what is wrong with it that
pixi is
suggested to be used here i have
authorization code grant
um on this screen on the
screen so it was originally suggested
for mobile application
but um and now it is actually used by
confidential and public
clients so the the base of this grant
is to exchange the authorization code
for an
access token what does it mean so this
uh
flow has two steps so first one
is in front channel which is the latin
which is less secure
and um like um it is real like for
example browser
so which like uh in this step
uh like um there is a call for um
like um the authorization server
and it results in authorization code
which represents um
the outcome of this uh front and
front channel operation right so here
you see on the screen
on the screen on on the right so the
first call which is happening
after that the user returned to the
client via the redirect url right which
was passed in the first call
and then application gonna get the
authorization code from the url
and use it actually to request an access
token
so the second call is a back channel
which is highly secure
one and from
in this step there would be a exchange
of this code which received in the first
system
with the access token um so on the
second
step and the confidential clients need
to send their secret but for
public ones as we said they don't keep
the secrets safe
so they won't send the secret right uh
so like um
and but what is wrong with this right so
why it is
suggested to use pixi on the top of that
because it it
looks to be like something good
right good enough but like do we sell
some some common attacks
on the authorization code flow the first
attack that i wanted that i'm showing
you
is about stolen authorization code
which is for public clients which is
very common for public clients what you
see on a screen is an
example of an authorization code
interception attack
which is happening on the smartphones
right so
in because uh public public clients
which
don't have a secret it seems if a
malicious app is still the code
it can exchange it with the access token
and abuse the protected
resource right as you see on the screen
in this smartphone it is possible to
register a malicious app
alongside with the
uh with the honest app and just receive
the access code and then try to exchange
it with the
access token because there is no secret
involved as well
um in this case so this is for public
clients
so next attack i'm gonna talk um with
you about is
authorization code injection attack this
is an
attack which is not so common but it is
happening and it is a common i mean it
is happening for
the confidential client
and this is this attack is actually very
hard to visualize
and draw a picture so i'm gonna try to
explain it that's
how it works so in this attack as um
like the attacker obtained the
authorization code actually by
intercepting it so just imagine in
in this attack the attacker and also the
honest app
they are actually using the actual
client means that the attacker have a
machine with the actual client on it
but then the attacker obtained the
authorization code by intercepting like
for example just imagine
having a blush like malicious browser
extension installed and like installed
on the honest um
client so then the attacker perform a
regular
uh oauth authorization process with the
legitimate
client on their device and then that
attacker injects a stolen
authorization code which was from the
honest client
in the response of the authorization
server um
to the legitimate client right so the
client sends the code to the
authorization server's
token endpoint along with the client id
client secret
uh and actual redirect qri right the
authorization server
here what does it check it checks the
client secret it checks
whether the code was issued to the
particular client and whether the actual
radar requiring match
and all of them actually matching here
so if all succeed which does the
authorization server issues access and
other tokens to the client right and now
the attacker is
able to impersonate the legitimate user
so and this is the attack for
confidential clients
so and now we prove that like we try to
prove that authorization code flow is
not safe for
public and also confidential client uh
here comes pixie pixie or perfect for
code exchange was
actually was suggested originally for
public client but
as we discussed now it is suggested or
it is actually mandated but by oauth 2.1
to be used for a public and also
confidential client
right so what does it do so
pixi in simple word it just introduced a
random secret created by the
calling application that can be verified
by authorization server
this secret is called code verifier
and um
additionally so the the calling gap
creates a
transform value of the code verifier
called code challenge
and send it over https tour street and
to
uh receive the authorization code you
see on this
on the screen on the right where i am
showing the calls
that the code challenge that we talked
about is sent
actually to get the code right and uh
so and um later when
it is asking for exchanging that code
read the access token it's going to send
the verifier the plain one
to the server so then with pixi with
this uh
like maintenance happened on the
authorization
and code flow so the code challenge
and code now are tied together right
so it means that if if they don't match
the server would not return the the
access token um so pxe
actually protect against um csrf or
and cross site request forgery as well
and with the same mechanism that it used
so it's like
and just imagine that as a like every
time
it's like a one-time secret and every
time the client is authenticated
and so far it is actually protecting
against attacks that i
explained so on the pixi so
you see the on the screen you see on the
first call redirect uri right
so like the next suggestion is about
that redirect url
it's a redirect uri must be compared
using exact
string matching so uh this means that
the authorization server
must utilize exact matching of the
client redirect url
and uri against the pre-registered uri
right
so um the wildcard was compliant with is
actually compliant with oauth 2.0 but
now with uh
over 2.1 it wouldn't be compliant
and um so
here i have um actually a couple of
um i mean i have these urls showing you
that for example if the registered one
is a wildcard one so the valid
and also the attacker both gonna work
right
um it's like having um um
exact um rhetoric you're right going to
help to detect the mixed up attack as
well
mix-up attacks is actually a very
complex attack but it
it comes in a picture when a client
needs to deal with different
authorization servers right um
the next um change such as that is about
implicit grant
so it say that the implicit grant is
emitted from the specification
so what is this implicit grant so it was
previously recommended
for interactive clients uh without a
secret like a js client like a
javascript client right
so the primary reason that implicit
grants and came to picture was because
of
a limitation in browsers right they
couldn't
make a cross-site ajax call and then
normally
the um like authorization server is
hosted on
another domain and they couldn't do that
initial post which was
required for authorization code flow
right
but there is no more issue anymore
because um now nowadays
and it's fixed with course and they can
do
actually cross-site ajax calls right so
but let's see what is implicit grant and
then why
it is uh not to be used so if you see
here on the screen so i have the calls
happening on the implicit grant
in implicit to just simplify to remove
that post
that we talked about on authorization
code it's just um there is a call
simply to the authorization server
asking for the token and just
return the token the access token in the
url
back to the client right so if
like this way there is couple of
actually damages
may happen first of all the token can
leak because the token is returned
in the url right it can leak on blog
files browser history
before headers and proxies and wherever
that like whoever can access this url
like any other
javascript um which is on the browser
they can access this token right
and so it also can cause um access token
injection
so this is about injecting a stolen
access token into a legitimate client
on a device under the attacker control
right and in this attack actually the
attacker wants to impersonate
a victim and cannot use um their own
client because um
they want to access certain functions on
this particular client right
so and um
because this aspect actually was not
originally safe
so the the aspect provides no mechanism
to return like a
refresh token and it's suggested to just
have the
a very very short uh like uh
life lifetime and also limited scope and
implicit and that's why now it's
um an over 2.1 it would be gone
for good the next thing which is omitted
from
spec is actually the resource
owner password grant or like
um some may know it as a password grant
so this actually this grant is
in securely exposes the credentials of
the resource owner
and also it just brings this bad habit
that user insert
their password all over the place and
not just in one
um unique place which is the
authorization server right
so here is a password grant i'm i try to
show you that
um how simply just the username password
of the research owner is actually sent
over the authorization server so
it is actually against the main
it was there for migration purpose
originally and it's against
one of the main concerns of oas which
was
password like avoiding password
anti-pattern
uh the next change is actually about the
bearer tokens
so uh bird tokens as we said are the
most commonly used um
access token types so it say that bird
tokens um
like um shouldn't be used on query
string of uri as
as we see uh as we saw on the implicit
that's exactly what was happening that
was
that's that's the implicit gonna have
problem with
this fact as well right so very tokens
as we said they are known
um also known as um
access tokens they actually led us to
access their protected resources right
so most tokens are arch or
jaw and but originally when the oh what
came out they paralleled to be on the
header on the post bodies and also on
query strings but now it is
uh it is actually
um it is prohibits and the spec
prohibits
the bearer tokens from being sent in the
query string
and um like as we said um at the curvy
string
and more generally any data in the url
is never private and any
javascript executing on the page can
actually access that
it's um it can actually leak into log
files as we said in the cache in the
browser history
and in general if you want to pass
information
privately over the internet use tls
first which is the key and also put the
sensitive
information in the post body or http
header and not
in the url
so here comes like the grand types um
limited for oat 2.1 so
which are limited now to client
credentials and pixi
the last point is about refresh tokens
refresh tokens
um allow a client to retrieve new access
token readout re-authentication right
so the the award 2.1 it say that
refresh tokens for public clients might
either
might must either be sender constraint
or one-time use what does this mean
so let's first see what is refresh token
how does it work
right so here is actually an abstract
picture
showing how refresh tokens works right
so um
like like when we get a token there
would be a reference token
um in the in the access token response
and we can exchange that in the first
call on the right as you see
so the client can exchange that for a
token
right there on the bottom and under the
call you see the response right and in
the picture it shows that
as long and as long as reference token
is available to client client can
actually
get another refresh token and this cycle
can go forever
so then if the refresh token leak so it
would
it may bring a very huge damages to the
system right
for for confidentials the secret is
required that's why
oat 2.1 just mentioned it for the public
clients right
but um for public clients it say
um there is do two things one time
password
and one time refresh talk and use what
does this mean means that
like uh like um after it like after
refresh token is
used to retrieve the access token it
becomes invalid
means that if there was a leakage it
would be
abused just once and there is a hope
that client
went because like just imagine an
attacker
um intercept their refresh token and
then they try to use it
and then after that the um honest um
client trying and they get error and
like they're gonna get notified that
something
wrong is happening right and the the
second thing was about
um being a sender constraint right
it means that ensure um the oh like it's
same
for the authorization server and to
ensure and that um
the refresh token and client i are
binds together cryptographically
so means that each client can ask for a
reference token and the same client can
use that right so and it ensured that
the request came from the client to
which the reference token was
issued so there is um like a multiple
suggested implementation for this
including like using or what token
binding or
mutual uh tls authentication
i am i'm gonna actually i'm i want to
try to explain the token binding
for uh refresh tokens and it's um
interesting for me so like um for for
token bindings enter
like uh from left to right there is two
calls
involved right if you see on the left so
you see um like a normal post
to get token to exchange code for token
in
uh pixie right so um
here like um but there is in the token
binding
actually in the spec introduced a new
http header named
security token bindings you see in the
picture that
once um once client is acting
asking for the access token it actually
set that header
right so it is um it it is carrying a
base
a 64 url encoded value for that token
binding message which just client is
aware of right
and then it gets the refresh token and
the next time when
um when the client wants to actually
exchange this
reference token um with an actual token
it sets the same value in the header
right
so this means that um like
in the first call the authorization
server um has
bound this refresh token to the provided
token binding id from that encoded
message in the header right so and then
like
when we do this enhancement like um the
response may look
like um the one on the right on the
bottom
and you'd like because um and just
having access token because now
reference tokens can be long lived
right because they are safe and they are
bound
to the client
uh so we we are um we actually went
through everything about oh what 2.1
now like i want to actually talk about
the openid connect and how
what's what's going to happen to openid
connect so open id connect just
um to just give you a better
like picture is the open standard for
authentication
right um it it actually came in the
picture as a simple identity layer on
the top of
a watt and is extending over 2.0
for authentication scenarios and it is
it is developed by openid working group
the openid connect and i
tried to show in the picture that open
id connect actually stand on the top of
oauth 2.0 so
on open id connect there is some new
concepts
like id token which is a jwt as well
contains uh like um scopes
about the user the current logged in
user and also
and the user info endpoint and um
which returned and the data about user
there is some
standards for scope and also there is
some standard for implementation as well
which suggests how to implement open id
connect
and here is like a big picture of how it
works
and um like um just to show
like him it is um on the top of actually
a lot so i'm not gonna
dig into open eye deconic i just wanted
to show you
that as far as we are concerned in the
scope of
this session so it's just it um
the future of open8d connect is that it
would be um
like the same thing but on the top of
all what 2.1
okay so i am um done with my slides
i'm gonna actually show you a quick demo
um i'm i want to show you a quick demo
of using m identity server for which
is an open open source library for
oauth2 and open id connect
um just bear with me for a second
to be able to actually
share my screen with you
okay
please let me know if you have any
issues in my screen
okay here i have
um on my demo i wanna actually
show you a couple of these um grants
that's um like i showed you on a what
2.0 and then as far as we are concerned
like the implementation has no change
just there is some enhancement uh which
we need to do
so here on my demo i have uh i have
like a demo ready for you so it contains
of
identity server which is actually the
authorization server
i have couple of clients ready and i
have an api
uh which is our resource right
and for the clients i have some public
clients
which is a razer client and a javascript
client and also a
confidential which is envy cyclone so i
want to show you simply how simple is um
to actually log in using
the yeah a lot
right so here i have my api running
and um
[Music]
here is my javascript client right so
i'm gonna actually
show you that network as well
so on my election i i i'm not intending
to show you
i have to do a good ui or something like
this this is just a very simple demo
just to show you
like pixie so here on my javascript
client
what i have done is very simple i came
and and then i i registered my client
right if you see my here i have my
javascript client
which is simply register so i mentioned
that the
the grant type that i'm going to use is
the code
authorization code but also i said with
enhanced pixy right
and i am saying that i need a consent
and um also i say that this is a public
client means that there is no need for
a secret and the redirect uri
i registered the exact uri means that
there is no wild card
and if like um
it wouldn't work with any other url
right
so here i come here i say okay
do a login and then when it comes to
logging it
actually redirects me to first
okay so i say okay just
um do a login first so when i'm when i'm
drawing
like as you see i am redirected to the
authorization server
this is what we want to see a unified
login string
on the authorization server
and i will try to log in
and once i logged in i see the consent
right
so and then
i am allowing here and then it is a
logged in a state
and then now if i try to actually
call an api it is called here in the
screen i want it actually to show you
something
so like if you see like in in case of
security so
like i want to show you the token
right
here is the token call as i mentioned it
is
um it is done on back channel and it is
secure there was a post
and there would be no leakage of
like i mean nobody can see that what is
happening right
so but this was a public client and i
have actually a private
a confidential client here available as
well
so for this one it's your logged in
because the identity server obviously is
logged in
and
okay now because i actually forced that
it asked me
for login
and again so here i am logged in
and i can call the api sending the
token so um like
i want to actually show you the
difference between
the that confidential client
and so here is my confidential client
as you see my confidential client is
exactly same registration
but what is happening is that first i
have client secret registered
and also like i'm using pixie but i
didn't say no need for
like a secret and also the return urls
right
so to to show you like a
tiny bit of like uh like a
tiny bit of how to go from inclusive to
the code with pixie
i actually made two clients ready for
you
so first is the implicit and the second
one is using code flow using pixi
so if you see here i just i'm showing
you simply the registration that how
easy i could go from implicit
i'm going to show you the clients as
well so
from implicit to the code flow with the
pixi right um so this one is
implicit and it doesn't mention the
required pc and also
it doesn't need to say that require
secret is false but here all i did was
to change the
flow to code and also saying the pixel
now i'm going to show you actually the
actual client code
the visual studio is unhappy
exactly work
and i stop it okay
so here is my actually here is my razor
client
um there is a client that i have using
implicit all it does is that okay
now i want to use the i want to use
identity server like i'm i'm logging
using open id connect it's just saying
that okay i wanna
i wanna my authority is that
authorization server i showed you
and this is my client id and that's all
right but then like when i did that
client with pixie so what i did the
enhancement i did
which wasn't very hard was to just say
okay
now like the response type now is code
that's all everything else is managed by
the library
so the main purpose of me showing you
this demo is to show if you pick
a proper library if you pick the proper
service provider how easy would be to
implement this
and like developers that are developing
the applications or the apis are not the
ones dealing with all the specs right
so they are the ones to just make sure
that the library
or the service that they are using is
actually providing
all the required and suggested things in
this spec
the other thing i wanted to actually
show you is
their refresh token and just show that
sam
how like to have a refreshed i mean how
to
retrieve refresh token and how to
and use it or how to use the bear token
to call api
here i've got my api and my
mvc app which is logged in
so here i am in my
controller if you see i can like in name
using.5 it's so easy like
now i have the refresh token available
which i could actually
use it i have my id token as reset for
i didn't like open id connect and i have
my access token right
here simply what i'm using is to just
put that access token in a barrier
and call an api
i put it in the header and i just call
the api and this
is there
so the other thing that i wanted to show
you was about the concept
so when i log out
and then when i log in again
so what i'm going to do is that in the
consent for example i say i don't want
the user to have this access
right so here i go here and then now
if i try to call an api i can't because
i don't have the access but this user in
fact it
originally had the access because if
i just provide it to them so what is
happening
is that
is that if i call this delete api it's
going to work means that it's just to
demonstrate how to
remove like simply remove scope or an
access from user using the consent form
um as far as i am concerned i'm
um done with demo but like i want to
leave some time for questions if there
is any
and please unmute yourself
if you want to ask any question or if
you want me to show you anything in the
code i know the code part is more
interesting part
but like uh feel free to just show me if
i mean tell me if you want me to show
anything in the code
okay
[Music]
thank you so much hi hi there
hi mike
i have to keep my hand on the space once
it keeps picking up
um i was just going to ask with regard
to um
the clients um do you think in
uh author 2.1 i'm just trying to work
out whether
i kind of asked a single question in one
of the earlier sessions
it was about um blazer and
oauth 2. and what i'm trying to figure
out is whether you think that
in the future um is it kind of
appropriate that public clients should
hold
um you know like id tokens and access
tokens
themselves or do you think you will go
in a direction where
public clients will be forced to have a
private back end and
session management will be between those
two
and you know all the id tokens and the
access tokens will
stop in the you know the private part of
the application
oh you you said that you you um like
like blazers right blazer applications
and
for the future is that what you said
yeah
exactly like this
so i like him i don't think that the
future going to be
to have actually like a
like a server in between like mvc so
i believe the public clients and like
browser-based ones
they are intending to stay browser-based
and uh like um to be more secure not
saving things on the client
like the access token and reference
token you me right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so to be safer
like i don't i don't
like i don't believe that the direction
gonna be to save them actually i mean to
have
like something in between as an
intermediate like a server-side
thing to save the stuff like it would be
more to
not saving anything on the client and
just
buying more overhead but but this is
actually a very very subjective thing
right
it depends to your client and like for
example for
for the ones that you want more security
maybe you just
buy that overhead and you say okay i
want slower why not saving and just
going
through server to retrieve an access
token every time
and rather than for the ones that um
like the security is not
that big of issue and you say okay i
want to just
save it and just deal with the like
damage it may but in the public client
if you didn't save anything on the
public client how would you
would you keep having to go back to the
identity provider to get the id token
every time you wanted to initiate
requests for an authorization
[Music]
for the id token for the access token
right
i i guess were you saying that you
thought that the client the public
client shouldn't persist
either the id token or the access token
obviously
you know what i'm trying to say is that
um it would be
it would be dependent to the client if
they want very very secure things yeah
they may develop to just go to the
server every time
but this is yeah as i said this is
totally depends to the business and to
the
client but as far as um um like
i know the direction is um to just
keep keep that in the client and i mean
keep the client
in the browser and not having something
on the server okay
okay thank you okay i i guess that's it
thank you so much
you